do you Ponder your death your mortality
are you afraid of it I am a cryonics
customer that's what this little tag
around my deck says it says that if you
find me in a medical situation uh you
should call these people to enable the
cryonex transfer so I am taking a long
shot chance at Living a much longer life
can you explain
what cryonics is so
when Medical Science gives up on me in
this world instead of burning me or
letting worms eat me they will freeze me
or at least freeze my head and there's
damage that happens in the process of
freezing the head but once it's frozen
it won't change for a very long time
chemically it'll just be completely
exactly the same
so future technology might be able to
revive me and in fact I would be mainly
counting on the brain emulation scenario
which doesn't require Reviving my entire
biological body it means I would be in a
computer simulation
and so that's I think I've got at least
a five percent shot at that
and that's immortality are you
excuse me most likely it won't happen
and therefore I'm sad that it won't
happen do you think immortality is
something that you would like to have
well I mean just like Infinity I mean
you can't know until forever which means
never right so all you can really you
know the better choices at each moment
do you want to keep going so I would
like at every moment to have the option
to keep going
the the interesting thing about
Human Experience is that
the way you phrase it is exactly right
at every moment I would like to keep
going
but the thing that happens
uh you know leave them wanting more of
whatever that uh right that phrase is
the thing that happens is over time
uh it's possible for certain experiences
to become Bland and you become tired of
them and that actually
makes life
um really unpleasant
that sorry makes that experience really
unpleasant and perhaps you can
generalize that that to life itself if
you have a long enough Horizon and so it
might happen but might as well wait and
find out but then you're ending on
suffering you know so in the rare world
of brain emulations I have more options
that you can return yourself I I can
make copies of myself archive copies at
various ages and at a later age I could
decide that I'd rather replace myself
with a new copy from a younger age
so does a brain emulation
still operate in the physical space so
can we do what do you think about like
the metaverse and operating in virtual
reality so we can conjure up not just
emulate not just your own uh brain and
body but the entirety of the environment
well most brain emulations will in fact
suppose most of their time in virtual
reality but they wouldn't think of it as
virtual reality or just think of it as
their usual reality I mean the thing to
notice I think in our world most of us
spend time most time indoors and indoors
we are surrounded by walls covered with
paint and Floors covered with tile or
rugs most of our environment is
artificial
it's constructed to be convenient for us
it's not the natural world that was
there before a virtual reality is
basically just like that it is the
environment that's comfortable and
convenient for you
and but if if when it's the right that
environment for you it's real for you
just like the room you're in right now
most likely is very real for you you're
not focused on the fact that the paint
is hiding the actual studs behind the
wall and the actual wires and pipes and
everything else the fact that we're
hiding that from you doesn't make it
fake or unreal